your new album is called Rita Wilson
noun forever Duets yes so it's heavily
inspired by the 70s yes yeah all cover
songs from the 70s and sort of
re-envisioned as conversations and Duets
right because I was thinking what if
these songs were actually conversations
that people were lovers were having with
each other yeah so I get to sing with
amazing people like Smokey Robinson
Willie Nelson Keith Urban Leslie Odom
juice a lot of people I mean yeah it's
Elvis Costello yeah so um it's it's
what's it like asking like you know what
I'm saying like when you ask that like I
I get nervous yeah because it doesn't
matter like how many awards whatever you
do you're still very nervous about like
or you could just say no it's a dumb
idea right I don't know what symptoms I
guess at all I like literally yeah like
I give them the out right away like I
think maybe you would want to do this
seriously but it's okay if you don't
want to as a matter of fact I'm hanging
up right now I guess what's up I just
don't want to hear the no but I know
that I might hear a no but in this case
very lucky very very humbled by
everybody who was able to show up that's
awesome it's really great my my uh
co-producer Matt Rawlings is an amazing
producer and he had worked with Willie
Nelson on Willie Nelson's Gershon and
Sinatra albums and so Willie was the
first person to say yes and we did Slip
Sliding Away together Paul Simon's song
and uh very very beautiful did you hang
out on his bus
because I have
and I didn't partake and yet still
walked out feeling fine contact high
contact no I did not hang out on his bus
but this year he sent me hemp tea and
coffee and he's got his own hemp tea and
coffee yeah he and his wife Annie you
know that for Christmas he's a
connoisseur so I would trust his product
yeah it's good for the muscle
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]